[Musique]
j'ai toujours été un rêveur
ce faisant les professions s'étaient
passé le mot à mon sujet je me rappelle
d'un professeur monsieur long qu'à
chaque jour et map était monsieur firmin
décembre et de là haut vous êtes encore
dans la lune c'est que pour monsieur mon
cas comme pour monsieur tout le monde
l'imaginaire est un espace de liberté
d'évasion où le temps n'existe pas c'est
encore un espace il lui est impossible
de soumettre ou contre un dans l'esprit
et l'artiste figure incomparable de la
liberté si ressources afin de nous
éclairer d'une lumière nouvelle c'est
que nous nous figurerons l'imaginaire de
l'artiste et l'imaginaire d'une manière
générale un peu comme ceux ci un espace
incommensurable étoilé est vaste
visualisez comme ceux ci il apparaît
littéralement impossible à coloniser et
puis on peut comprendre monsieur lancar
et l'urgence qu'il avait à me faire de
cette descente de là-haut et moi avec la
tête
dans la lune ou plutôt dans les étoiles
je fus diriger vers l'âge de 16 ans vers
une formation en arts et depuis je n'ai
jamais cessé d'ajouter aux formations
personnel des formations académiques et
pendant trente deux ans à bord j'ai
cherché à savoir ce qu'est ce que
c'était
cet espace où je passe le plus clair de
mon temps imaginaire maintenant faisons
une expérience de pensée
imaginons que l'imaginaire ce n'est pas
ce lieu commun que nous venons de voir
mais qu'il pourrait ressembler plutôt un
système informatique
donc visualisera comme ceci donc une
sorte de réseau collectif nous
permettant de penser d'imaginer
d'échangé à partir d'un ensemble de
logiciels dédiés aux images aux idées à
la langue au conseil etc se le figurer
comme ceci sous-entend alors une chose
c'est que vous et moi qu construisons
l'imaginaire et si on continue
l'analogie du système informatique
alors il devrait exister un moyen de le
pirate les avez vous entendu parler de
l'icône haute estime oui non
il consiste ou du moins elle consiste en
la destruction des supports visuels qui
servent à un peuple a coagulé son
imaginaire collectif
elles s'accompagnent généralement
d'autres formes de destruction comme la
réécriture de l'histoire
rappelez-vous les vols les autodafés
autour des biens et écrit des peuples
juifs par le régime nazi
visualisez à travers l'histoire de
l'humanité les temples lieux de pouvoir
palais château fort détruits ainsi que
les images d'objets de culte rites et
coutumes système d'écriture eux aussi
détruit rendu illégaux ou tout
simplement remplacés par ceux du
vainqueur cela ne fait il pas penser un
piratage culturel
vu sous cet angle l'occident
colonisateur du monde
nos pertes il pas un piratage système en
modifiant supprimant chez les peuples
colonisés une part de leurs codes le
piratage des imaginaires est un
comportement humain et millénaire
cependant les ans
toutefois nonobstant
c'est la première fois dans notre
histoire qu'a vainqueur pirates toutes
les cultures simultanément il en résulte
une fragilisation de l'écosystème
culturel planétaire désormais il n'est
plus question de pays ou de groupes
ethniques la catastrophe et que les
différents imaginés endémiques sont
raturé biffé est avalée par un système
devenu viral et comme dans la nature
quand on organise même prolifèrent sans
résistance il met en danger tout
l'écosystème ainsi ne faudrait-il pas
restauré une forme d'équilibré alors je
vais me mettre à votre service et être
l'exemple de 7,17 décolonisation donc
refaisant connaissance bonjour chameau
nommé différemment je suis praticiens
visuel je viens d'une petite île la
guadeloupe
parallèlement je vis ici depuis une
décennie alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que l'on nous la guadeloupe est
généralement à désigner comme prototype
des sociétés multi et interculturel de
notre monde actuel
c'est aussi l'un des berceaux de la
créolité
c'est à dire une culture dont le
fondement est le devenir est la
diversité
en somme si pour les ans le fond de moi
l universalisme notre forme on serait
plutôt un pluri multi diverses alisme
c'est que ma culture naît d'une table
rase le génocide des peuples caraïbes
par les européens ainsi que la violence
coloniale et de l' esclavage
cette dernière tragédie la mettre en
relation d'innombrables culture
d'occident et d'afrique participants par
là même à créer la singularité ou la
singularité de ce qu'il est désormais
convenu d'appeler les petites antilles
ou petit caraïbes
mais est ce vraiment important de
restaurer un équilibre entre imaginaire
on regarde un tel bouillonnement
culturel
question rhétorique pour répondre à
cette question
j'ai mis en place une méthode elle
commence par trois questions qui
interroge tout mon ressenti première
question ai-je le sentiment de porter un
mois un imaginaire culturel large plus
gros que tous les autres seconds mon âge
le sentiment où le ressenti de porter un
mois une friction culturel et enfin
dernier point est ce que de manière
intime je ressens vous je porte du moins
une forme de sentiment d'injustice ou de
perte
même si je n'arrive pas à m'expliquer ce
que c'est alors si comme moi votre
réponse est oui alors une de vos
cultures à pirater toutes les autres les
autres abats vous ai quitté la thalassa
loulou ou éteindre la vidéo vous êtes
encore là
continuons
étape finale comment finalement établir
un dialogue véritable entre imaginaire
donc aux deux dents - comment y arriver
ou plus simplement commandé colonisé une
part de mon imaginaire il est important
de savoir comment l'imaginaire articule
nos ordinateurs culturel il s'établit
entre le personnel le collectif et les
institutions là dedans on retrouve
toutes les infractions social avec les
banques les écoles les ministères les
bibliothèques etc
l'imaginaire englobe nos manières
d'approcher la spiritualité la langue la
poésie et cetera
c'est un savoir flou qui nous permet de
comprendre le monde
un peu comme un code mathématiques qui
articule toutes nos échanges sociaux ce
code
je le nomme le code de remédiation dans
le cas d'une culture piratés
subalternité colonisé le code est
presque entièrement effacé comme
beaucoup de minorités
j'ai été déporté dans l'imaginaire
occidental
c'est à dire qu avait environ 91,93 23%
du code qui articule ma manière de
comprendre le monde mais légué par ma
part d'occident notamment avec l'école
qui m'apprend à voir et à comprendre
comme un accident talent néanmoins
l'objectif n'est pas la fin ou la mort
de l'occident rappelez vous la jeunesse
demi culture autant me tirer une balle
dans l'eau
mais rééquilibrer le système soit dans
l'absolu quelque chose comme ça entre
mes codes de remédiation d'afrique et
d'occident mais avant d'en arriver là
vision utopique y arriver avant d'en
arriver là
une question se pose est de taille
comment trouver le code de remédiation
pratiquement effacé de mes ancêtres en
occident l'un des grands code qui nous
permet de partager du savoir et le code
de la transparence
le code de la transparence nous permet
de faire ceci du microscope au télescope
l'objectif est de voir à travers les
choses pour pouvoir les reprendre dans
un autre contexte rappelez vous à
l'église le curé qui dit dieu voire un
point devant phil coke comprend un peu
comme superman à travers les murs
j'ai mis au point une méthode permettant
de pêcher les codes de remédiation au
travers d'une pratique de va et vient
entre récit écrit récit visuel support
de la pensée humaine
rappelez-vous les grottes de lascaux et
une cartographie de mon imaginaire
ratures et j'ai trouvé une part de ce
code qui jusqu'àlors m'échapper ce code
se nomme le code de l'indigénat bilité
en opposition au code de transparence de
l'occident c'est à dire du colon du m a
été formé un code de l'indigénat bilité
si en occident
le code est celui de la transparence
l'esclave produira en réponse un code de
l'indicé à l'habilité en opposition soit
un brouillage de l'information car il en
allait de sa survie étant artiste je me
suis intéressé à la présence de ce code
dans un art séculaire commun à toute la
caraïbe sa base commune est un mélange
de danse de tambours de contes et de
chant dans mon île
la guadeloupe
il s'agit du gros qu'à un art cet art
séculaire se nomme le gros calme et sa
manière d'appliquer les de l'indicé en
habilité se nomme la ligue ans et la
look ans est l'art de manier la parole
le chant la danse avec technicité et
brio ainsi sous le beau se cache un art
du double langage et de la ruse mais ce
n'est pas seulement
l'esclave des caraïbes qui a éduqué à
user d'un code similaire se sont tous
les esclaves des amériques
nous avons tous en tête les chants
d'esclaves dans les champs de coton ou
encore de manière contemporaine la
musique rap qui saoule indiscernable it
et des mots peut cacher un message de
résistance mais disons tout simplement
que dans ma culture lundi serna bilité
répond à la ligue ans et la loco
décompose trois logiques le beau le
camouflage et la résistance en tant
qu'artiste j'ai pressé toi logique et
les est injecté dans ma pratique d'arts
visuels contemporaine ainsi que dans ma
vie afin de rééquilibrer mais deux
imaginaires et leurs codes de
remédiation donc voici à peu près ce que
ça donne dans ma pratique
pour vous donner à penser à mon sujet et
aux vôtres
culturellement je ne suis pas composé
que de fric et d'occident
[Applaudissements]